[Music]
why I just got happy at the end you guys
imagine give him some great comedy oh no
no no this is true this is their real
first up QVC okay you go on the QVC
channel there's QVC and I didn't quite
know what was going on so I checked for
the description I push the info button
it says old bags selling new bags quite
helpful then I was watching Sons of
Anarchy yeah
watching Sussman and I didn't notice why
that's pushed on the info button and it
says Gossip Girl for dudes yeah
then there's here comes honey boo boo
yeah there comes honey boo boo and then
you you push the info button and it says
look at this vivid reminder that the
North won here we go here's Monday Night
Football checking out Monday Night
Football and look what it says right
here for info wealthy men take a
three-hour break from murdering
yeah moving on we got diners look at
this diners drive-ins and dives franku
the popular show push the info button it
says to be played at Guy Fieri's autopsy
[Applause]
it's something else next one's Beverly
Hills pawn and if you watch that one
barely gong-shil onlooker this lady
yeah check the info button it says the
worst people ever sell stuff to the
second worst people ever put me around I
saw this one I saw Grey's Anatomy was on
yeah so I yeah and then it says yes it's
still on okay I'm moving on we got four
kids we got look at this
Teletubbies and it says I look
description it says overweight colored
blobs run around on astroturf to the
delight of no one then I checked out our
next show Real Housewives of Orange
County and it said overweight colored
blobs run around on athletes to the
delight have no line